[Music]
a passion
for ignorance comes actually
from psychoanalytic texts
by jacques lacan a french psychoanalyst
who has borrowed the term
passion for ignorance from buddhist
studies
it is known that in the 50s
jacqueline attended lectures on buddhism
at the parisian university
sorbonne and at that time
you know he was sort of kind of
following
the reasoning presented
also by a famous buddhist
monk who
wrote the book what the buddha
thought and it is from this kind of a
background that
you know lacan develops his own
take on ignorance why
a passion now the
first question is whether people truly
want to know and you know in
psychoanalysis
it is kind of usual that people come
to the first session with the idea that
they would like
to know about their suffering or what is
behind their suffering
that they would like to come to the core
of their potential
however very quickly analysts observe
that this desire to know
goes away and people quite often
embrace you know ignorance
or they embrace denial they embrace
negation which are or different
but like are heading in the slightly
similar
direction of not coming close
to some knowledge which might
exist in the unconscious so
a person's kind of conscious and his or
her
unconscious here are on two different
levels and so psycholysis observes
this ignorance in regard to the known
quite often being linked maybe to some
traumatic
experience that the person has repressed
pushed away pushed out of keys of her
consciousness
the other important thing is also that
the ignorance is in some way present
also on the side of the analyst
the analyst should not be in the
position
of the person who knows although
someone comes to analysis with the
perception
that you know the analyst is someone who
might
interpret something for them or dispose
important questions uh we should not
expect
that the analyst in the traditional
freudian postproduct
uh domain should be the one who
could guide you and give you advice
this is different from let's say
contemporary
coaches so the subject
in the way supposes that the analyst
knows
but the analyst needs to resist uh
in that kind of confidence that he or
she
actually has knowledge about the
patient's
you know unconscious desires uh which is
why
that is a position of ignorance the
subject
you know of the analyst actually should
be
you know a little bit almost like a kind
of an idiot
someone who does not in advance
uh claim a particular kind of
knowledge and allows the subject that
analyzant
to work through his or her desires
at his of her own pace of course the
analyst will you know pose important
questions will bounce back what he or
she
hears from from the analyzant
now the other important element when we
are talking about the passion for
ignorance
is sort of the ideology it's
sort of like the kind of the social
symbolic background
in which we live the so-called big other
you know what in la canyon
psychoanalysis is called the big other
and that is institutions language
written and unwritten rules
around us and you know especially
you know in a way culture but language
as such
that uh sort of is the principle element
through the process of socialization so
here we can see that there has been you
know a kind of
a ship from you know what
uh michelle pucco was in the second half
of the 20th century
talking about when he was kind of
analyzing the relationship
between power and knowledge today
we can say that there is an important
link between
power and ignore and
you know what is happening is that on
the one hand
we have terms like knowledge based
economy which appears you know
very enlightening as if our economy
truly is based on knowledge and also
you know we might have a wrong
perception
that knowledge is sort of shared it is
easily available
to appoint it is everyone now can go
and google however behind the knowledge
that
we get through you know the search
engines
uh are algorithms which are already
sorting
this knowledge you know they're creating
kind of a hierarchy
between informations which we don't know
exactly
how you know they are made the
hierarchies
how the uh algorithms operate
is often secret so
what we are more and more observing is
what
lindsay mcgoway a british sociologist
has called strategic ignorance
which is that those in power are
intentionally
playing with keeping people in the dark
now this happens for example with big
corporations
um especially you know when something
goes wrong we can observe
all kinds of denials at work
for example with the famous
british petroleum oil spill in the
mexican
gulf there was all kinds of
denials at work you know everyone in the
corporation appeared you know to be in
one way or another
you know in denial of what was actually
happening
and you know the question emerged was it
really possible that people
especially up in the hierarchies didn't
know about you know the dangers and when
the oil spill happened they still
denied what actually was going on or
you know was it that you know they were
simply in one way or another closing
their eyes now this kind of a strategic
ignorance is sort of part also
of the way information is transmitted
to people again you know quite often the
power mechanisms
use it to their advantage but another
type of
ignorance which is embedded with the
so-called knowledge
economy is discussed by
joan roberts and john armitage their
scholars in the domain of management
studies
and they claim that actually we should
rename
knowledge economy into ignorance
economy since it relies
on many strategies to limit
access to knowledge now some strategies
involve patents others
involve copyright and you know still
others
sort of are linked to the opacity
regarding
big data and we know that big data is
often called the new gold or the new oil
whoever has access to big data you know
has
enormous advantage uh in regard
to not know not only knowing potential
desires of people but as we have seen
with cambridge analytica also
they have not they have with the help of
big data
corporations like this the possibility
to manipulate
people's opinions and of course from
marketing we know
to manipulate people's uh desires
so these are kind of uh new elements
of ignorance which are embedded in the
way
society is functioning
now still different kind of
take on ignorance comes from philosophy
where through centuries now we have been
debating
what is there to be known and you know
sort of what is the power
of the unknown and here of course we
should not forget
the medieval philosopher and theologian
nicholas the kuza who invented the term
dr ignorantia learned
ignorance it was kuza who sort of
pointed out that what is important
is to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas